-This show sort of happene
for you --
I remember we first met
when you were doing...
-Yeah, yes, yes.
-...I think an off-Broadway play
right before this show started
-Yes, that's right.
-So you had this -- this sort of
maybe a little later
in your career
than you would expect
to have a show
that ran this long.
What was your
first entry into --
you know, the first time
you got an agent like?
-Oh, well, I had a rough -
I had a rough entry.
Like, I -- when I --
It was here.
In fact, I think about it ever
time I go through Times Square
Because I had moved here,
you know,
like many people,
for a relationship.
And now I found myself
in New York,
and this woman
that I was dating,
kindly enough,
set up a meeting with her agent,
and it was a legitimate agent.
It was, like, a real agent
It wasn't like a
"Broadway Danny Rose" situation.
-Right.
-So I was nervous.
I put on, like, my cool clothe
which was, like,
my black T-shirt
and black pants,
which has never been cool.
-No.
-Ever.
[ Laughter ]
-It is a good way to say,
"I'm an actor..."
-Yeah, totally!
-"...who right after this
has to go be a waiter."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not saying -- I'm not
saying I was wearing Capezios,
but I'm also not saying
I wasn't.
-Right. Sure. You don't
want to commit either way.
Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But anyway so, I --
I ended up going up,
and meeting and sat down
with a gentleman at the agency
who looked at my résumé,
which had like maybe two o
three regional theater credits
and, you know,
basically set it down
and sort of
looking me up and down,
and began telling me
all of the things
that were wrong with me
physically.
-Wow.
-He was like -- he was like,
"So, yeah. So your eyebrow
are too big for television."
[ Light laughter ]
"And your features are reall
too big for film."
And meanwhile, you know,
he's just confirming
my own self-loathing.
I'm like, "Yeah, uh-huh."
-You weren't -- right.
You didn't go in going like,
"Wait till he sees
these eyebrows."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
No. I was like, "Nailed it."
He's like,
"You got a weird chin."
I'm like, "Oh, it's a joke."
But, anyway, so he --
he basically says,
"Well, you know,
maybe you could do theater
Are you willing
to shave your arms?"
Which I was like --
[ Light laughter ]
And I was so desperate
to get an agent that I was like,
"Absolutely."
[ Laughter ]
Like,
"I'm dying to shave my arms!
[ Laughter ]
"Are you kidding?
I'm looking for an excuse
to shave my arms.
This is great."
And he said, "Great.
Shave your arms
and get new head shots,
and come back, and we'll hav
another conversation."
And then I kind of slinked out
of the office
and went downstairs
into Times Square,
and I was, you know,
just kind of, like,
mortified and devastated.
And I was standing there,
and as I was standing there,
I had a little accident
in my drawers.
I -- I soiled myself.
-You did?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And I remember thinking --
I remember thinking
really clearly, "Huh.
So this is the bottom."
[ Laughter ]
"This is it."
-Yeah, that's the bottom.
-"This is it."
[ Applause ]
-I mean, they do say
if you're gonna soil yourself,
Times Square
is as good of a place --
[ Laughter ]
-It's amazing.
-'Cause you're probably only
half a block from someone else
who's like,
"I'm also there, buddy."
-I mean, Elmo soiled himself
-Elmo probably, yeah.
-Statue of Liberty
soiled himself.
-Soiled herself, yeah, exactly
You -- this is no joke.
This is a terrifying thing
that happened to you.
I guess it's probably about,
what, five, six years ago?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-There was an e-mail hack.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you were one of
the celebrities
who had your e-mail hacked
-Yeah. Yeah, like seven or eight
years ago I got a call --
There was this person who wa
hacking celebrity e-mails,
and he was arrested, and I got
a call from an FBI detective
saying, "You were one of
the people who was hacked.
And it really freaked me out
It was kind of crazy.
And he said -- you know, in this
phone call, I was like,
"So, why? Like, why is this gu
hacking people's e-mails?"
And the detective was like
"Well, he's selling information.
He was selling information."
He was selling it
to the tabloids.
He was selling photographs
and e-mails."
And I was like, "Wow.
So what did he sell of mine?
And he was like, "Um..."
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, nothing."
And I was like,
"What do you mean nothing?
And he was like,
"He couldn't find any takers."
[ Laughter ]
-"It wasn't
for a lack of effort."
-No!
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Wait.
He was actively
trying to sell my information,
and nobody wanted it?"
He was like, "Well, um...
Mr. Burrell, I've read through
all the evidence, and, frankly
you're pretty vanilla."
[ Laughter ]
And I went from feeling like a
victim to being super-defensive.
-Yeah.
-I was like,
"Uh, I think you need to go back
through those e-mails."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Go back through May 2002.
-Oh, yeah!
-"There's some stuff!"
-"There's some stuff!
Somebody missed
my chili recipe."
[ Laughter ]
"'Cause I don't think
everybody's putting nutmeg
in that, you know?"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm glad you avoide
the worst of that.
-Yes. Yeah, yeah.
-And congrats on this new show
This is Mike Scully,
a fantastic writer.
His wife -- is it, Judy?
-Julie.
-Julie, and Amy Poehler
all involved in the show.
And it is genuinely
so great to have you here.
Congrats on the amazing run.
-Thanks, man.